one thing they could have done oh this
is so good you just touched on a very
hard thing about doing the effects for
this movie hi hi doggie welcome back to
another episode of VFX artists react we
got some great things to look at today
and I'm looking forward to seeing
Clint's reaction to it all
I can't wait to react whoa dude okay so
this I'm ever really taking me off guard
cuz it's like he's missing half his face
and it looks incredibly realistic the
small detail with like the blood on the
left side of the pillow yes so
disgusting
see up into this point you know if you
want to crazy makeup effects you could
add it to somebody's face
you can never subtract from somebody's
face and that's what makes this so
jarring is because you can actually see
inside of this cheek so--but yeah look
at his eyeball look at the underside of
this eyeball you never see an eyeball
just exposed like that it emits this
visceral reaction of like oh dude you
can see his tendons like going across
his face they're a little bit like his
bone yeah poking through I'm also
noticing they're doing this very
cleverly - they're hiding most of it
most of the time a lot of people like to
say that Christopher Nolan does not like
visual effects he only ever does
practical effects but that's a misnomer
he's actually a huge fan of visual
effects he just uses them very
specifically two of his movies have one
the best visual effects Oscar in the 90s
when people started doing animation it's
like oh I can just make a 3d model and
I'll put bones underneath which will
morph and stretch and move the model
simple enough right well once he tried
starting to make things photorealistic
we suddenly realize that that didn't
look real because that's not how our
skin moves our skin doesn't just slide
around
we have muscles underneath our skin and
the muscles when they're tight they're
gonna bulge out and when they're loose
they're gonna say their cause wrinkles
and our skin is just on top of this web
of muscles and tendons that are pulling
things around so for something like to
face you need that complexity of the
muscles underneath pulling and you can
actually see the tendons sliding against
each other and it's all hand animated by
the way it's just a testament to us
starting to understand how to
humans in human faces what did they have
like any tracking markers what do they
do there so Christopher Nolan likes to
shoot his movies with a lot of darkness
right and you've probably seen facial
tracking where they have little black
dots in the face you're not going to see
the black dots on his face when he's in
shadow so they're using little white
markers but even then those are in
shadow right they fall into shadow and
you lose them so what they're actually
doing to track his face it's not the
main camera that's tracking his face
they actually have other cameras on set
and they have little ring lights around
them that are very very faint and that's
all retro reflective material all those
other cameras are seeing nice vibrant
bright dots even when it's in shadow
because of the retro reflective material
but the main camera isn't seeing that at
all it's a really ingenious way to have
motion tracking dots that you can see
with multiple cameras but not with the
main camera another cool thing is when
you're using multiple cameras you can
triangulate the positions of those dots
and get 3d motion tracking data out of
it so that's how they're tracking his
face to put the 3d model on it it's not
about what I want it's about what's fair
spoiler is he Pro hopefully you've seen
the movie by now he dies in the scene
where he's dead and like the rocking his
face back and forth his resting
expression he looks like he's smiling
even though he's just blank
there's happy there's happy Harvey Dent
was like wait that's no good he's
supposed to be sad now you know Mortal
Kombat was one of the better video game
movies that came out that was your
yearbook photo you usually when you do a
morph you try to pick landmarks that
stay the same like his eyeballs would
morph toward the dragon's eyeballs are
but instead his eyes turn into teeth so
this came out a year after Independence
Day it's a low-budget video game movie
it is I suppose that is true but here's
the thing there's a big difference
between bad visual effects and old
visual effects and with bad visual
effects its artists dropping the ball
producers getting too in the way of
artists trying to do their thing but
with old visual effects it's just the
limitation of the technology at the time
so like there's a technology thing you
know you got more so you got your basic
transitions you can't really get too
crazy with particles because you didn't
have the computer power for it back in
the day especially in the budget but
yeah one thing they could have done is
added a light that flickered at the same
rate as the lightning oh yeah yeah look
at that like everything is super bright
except for him he doesn't flicker at all
that would have taken these VFX shots to
the next level it's a t-rex thing from
Jurassic Park like they didn't have the
fancy lighting technology for that
either what they did to make up for it
was that they had very specific lighting
situations that you could replicate in a
computer and they had that same thing
going here but they didn't follow
through on it had they just had a
directional light source that matched
the Lightning it would have really made
a blend with the footage one thing about
Mortal Kombat though it's a fun movie
and at the end of the day even if the
visual effects are bad it doesn't
actually matter that much if it's a fun
movie yeah yeah this is very true
he's making me cry we're looking at
Captain America the First Avenger look
at him he's right there so skinny this
is like the perfect example of their
effect working great of making Chris
Evans skinny Chris Evans was ripped
during all the ripped
yeah cuz he was playing the final
version of himself and they didn't have
the time from be like skinny down and
then buff up so all these shots of
skinny Chris Evans are actually totally
buffed out Chris Evans wait are you for
real it's not just a skinny guy and then
they're putting Chris Evans face on the
skinny yes and no when they're actually
shot the movie they would shoot three
different takes and so they would shoot
the original shot with Chris Evans
buffed out Chris Evans so they would
shoot a second time with an actual actor
who was a tiny dude but the effects
company would basically just use him as
reference and only reference and then
they would also do a third take with
knowing than the shot at all like a
clean plate clean plate hell yeah they
feeling in all the all the space that
Chris Evans is including behind him so
first things first like this scene right
here that you're seeing the split screen
that's a straight up liquify and distort
and shrinking everything down like
making his arms skinny making us chest
skinny and just straight up distorting
your frame that seemed that where he
goes and talks to the the doctor for
being recruited that's a body double and
so times one is just like skin and he's
not wearing a shirt that's the double
basically this is an example of where
they used the smaller actor in composite
in Chris Evans's face on top of his
they just do a head replacement here but
he's still I've actually even skin a
fight they made him even skinnier
because apparently a small Steve Rogers
is still several inches shorter than the
small actor they used on set this is all
2d compositing they used a program
called flame for all of it
the same flame that was first used and
the Super Mario Brothers movie yes so
the company that does this visual effect
is called Lola visual effects I think
they're in London but they're
responsible for all of the de-aging
effects you've seen in Marvel movies you
know you have Kurt Russell Michael
Douglas younger Tony Stark they really
specialized in trying to like figure out
what parts of the body sag and so that
they know what parts they like soften up
and smooth out you definitely notice in
this shot here if Sir Patrick Stewart
when they smooth them over it definitely
kind of gives them that smooth look it
kind of looks less real because it is so
artificially smooth and you lose some of
the detail in the highlights you can
still see the wrinkles there that
reminds me actually of something that
was really unique about the Steve Rogers
can you Steve Rogers so we have texture
on our skin you know you have skin
plates you have hair follicles basically
grain right detail what happens when you
take something that's this big and you
scale it down what happens if you take a
big picture you scale it down it gets
sharper right it gets crisper so all of
that gave them a problem when when they
started shrinking him down all the
texture on him start getting a really
crisp even tiny compared to everything
else and on a movie screen you can see
it so they actually had to then after
they shrink him down they had to
basically denoise his skin and then
re-add grain and noise back to his skin
at the correct scale another layer they
had to add on top of that was d
shadowing yes because shadows are what
we use to cue us for like shape and
volume exact so big dude with giant pecs
cast shadows on his body and then we
take remove as the pecs is like what
were these shadows coming from no they
would de chateau-renaud o--'s everywhere
and then they would shrink it down cuz
they fade yeah like you're saying if
they just shrink it down with the
shadows it's like where did those
shadows come from it was a tremendous
amount of work no wonder Marvel movies
and movies like these have so many VFX
artists working on them for sure and
like this is true mastery of like the
human form if you ever wonder why
Leonardo da Vinci cuts open cadavers if
you can understand the anatomy and the
muscular structure
then you know what to draw when you're
drawing something from reference and
from your mind so as you know you can
always leave a comment down below to
help inspire us as to what we should
react to next but if you'd like a more
direct way to interact with us we run a
poll on patreon for every VFX artists
react for you guys to pick one of our
scenes and skinny Steve Rogers was one
of them
so consider supporting us on patreon
coms left corridor digital or there's a
link in the description below alright
let's check out the next one why don't
you watch this so many times it's just
goofy it's like the REA same reason why
you wash Birdemic there's bad that's
intentionally bad which is never good
and there's trying to make it good and
it turned out bad and that's hilarious
to watch and ultraviolet is a case of
the latter oh man what a mess
look at those those particles shooting
out of this side of the building there
when she's goes straight up are they
tracked they're not you're right they
just drift why are they drifting who
they're not tracked this place okay
obviously physics have just been 100%
ignored it's true
[Music]
wiggle wiggle what what okay hold up
would you turn over gravity bill what is
happening right there some poor artists
I'm sure is having to hand track this
into the shot way after the fact with no
tracking data I think you're right Nikko
I think the motorcycle is 100% real yeah
I think so and they're just having to
deal with the the footage plates of that
because everything is green screen here
was that an attempted retiming there too
when she falls to the guys out of me see
the wheel motorcycles probably just like
hung on wires or something like that
they're trying to mimic the perspective
it will have yes which is a good idea
honestly it's like if you want to get
these crazy motions that's a pretty
solid that's not how mirrors work it's
not how mirrors work the respective
doesn't change in the mirror at all it
just becomes flat the whole time all the
pyramids are just spewing out steam in
the background all the pyramids they
broker just steam it out
[Music]
well whoa that was cool the gun it's too
late man no coolness is gonna save this
movie
dude the smooth-skinned hill turn is
killing me
a movie took photoshop's unsharp mask
filter and applied it for their look
unsharp mask us right now just just make
us look like ultraviolet there you have
it they did get one thing right the
helicopter blade motion blur is making
the blue of the sky darker not just
great what yeah you're right look at
that they're actually the so motion blur
like that is it acts like an ND filter
it pulls your exposure down for things
behind it and you're getting correct
exposure adjustment on the buildings in
the sky behind those helicopter blades
and they got that right how did they get
that right but they can't track in
particles because you have like five VFX
artists staying up 24 hours a day just
trying to get this done
yep yep yeah exactly what's going on by
the way guys this whole movie is gold
please watch this movie next time you
get a chance watching it at
one-and-a-half speed with the sound
still on is the preferred way to watch
it it's way funnier
oh this is so good all of you pause this
video right now and go watch this whole
series it'll take you like 15 minutes
then come back and finish watching this
this is super cool I love this dude the
way his eye cracks and the blood bubbles
up
oh I never noticed the blood before
that's the thing like I know it's a new
detail every time i watch this see I
know nothing about Warhammer 40k or
anything like that I know nothing about
the universe
or the IP at all but this was so cool
yeah everything is perfect about this
the lighting the action the camera
movement wasn't this made by like one
gosh that's that's what's incredible all
of the modeling and animation and
rendering and compositing and editing
and sound design and color grading and
publishing so there's two things that
really inspire me about this one is the
fact that we've gotten to the point
technologically where one guy has the
tools to be able to make this he's able
to make it look this good on his
computer secondly is that there's all
these little details being pulled for
more warhammer Laurie diesel pronounced
let's start tell us about all the cool
details in this you go told me about
this this is basically one of the cool
things I've ever seen I'm a huge
Warhammer fan so the great thing about
these shorts is that every single aspect
and every single cool action setup piece
is an actual mechanic in the game from
the weapons they use like the plasma
pistol the plasma pistol has like a
really high armor penetration which is
why it was able to get through that the
whole like he's doing a shooting
movement and then he's doing his charge
phase and then he's doing combat phase
like this is just like a really sped up
version of playing Warhammer on the
tabletop if this guy doesn't get hired
by Games Workshop and make a full-length
movie then they're they're messing up
hard thanks T so you'll notice a lot of
things in this like depth the field
motion blur nice lighting good shadows
back in the day used to have to
basically turn on all these things one
by one and dial them in until they
looked real it was all just hacks so
these days if you learned that
physically based rendering program like
octane or redshift
octane is our renderer we love octane it
actually makes it much much easier to
make something like this look real in
fact it takes a lot of the work out
octane just turn it on put it in a light
and it's like well that looks awesome it
feels like cheating at first and then
your
this is it this is all I needed but this
is like where the technology's gotten to
which is wonderful because it's all just
there already just turn it on and
simulate it and that's the beautiful
thing about it it just say it gets
technology out of the way for the artist
and just lets artists create and I think
a star DS is one of the best examples of
that you should definitely check it out
it's an amazing animation we'll have a
link in the description below yeah I've
seen that movie home alone we have this
idea what if we made home alone the
rated-r version hello like what would
happen if you took a brick to the face
from five stories up and probably cave
your nose in like that one scene in
Pan's Labyrinth so subscribe so that you
can find out when we put it out if you
would like to see us react to a TV show
or movie something that you are a big
fan of please leave a comment down below
and we will take a look yes we've heard
all your quests from Bollywood don't
worry we are going to be doing a
Bollywood episode soon it's gonna be
real good we got a subreddit our /border
letting it escape from below
we got merch I'm wearing some our merch
right now I love it one of my favorite
shirts quarter digital dot store also
we've got an Instagram Instagram coms
last quarter digital or just at Quora
Digital all these things are in the
description please consider following
we've got a bunch of cool stuff in all
the channels lots of good stuff coming
up make sure you subscribe to the
channel hit that
[Applause]